I looked at your Blaze and I was like
this thing is beautiful 44 reg bro 44
right
I was shopping for you now it's nice man
I lost all the weight I lost 150 pounds
a little I have a few critiques about
being skinny though like okay talk to me
well first of all when you're skinny the
ankles are too tight I don't want to do
yoga to get out of my pants that's where
I miss my fat boy pants that's true
because you could drop them and step out
like a fireman so it's little things but
for the most part all good okay is your
wardrobe dramatically changed yeah man I
get to shop at other stores now which is
nice you know I used to have to shop at
the Big and Tall store my whole life now
I can go into Macy's like Willy Wonka I
walk in and say come with me that fits
that fits that fits so it's been a real
gift you know on top all the health
stuff that was the big thing that you
were dealing with type 2 diabetes gone
now gone man no diabetes resting
heartbeat went from 113 to 68 walking
around pretty healthy these days of
course there's always people online that
you know when I was Heavy they're like
you're too heavy and now it's like are
you sick can I just walk to the Earth
please can I just be happy and you it
seems like like you have you found this
happening yeah man you know I think you
got to find peace with yourself and at
some point look in the mirror and go you
know it's probably time to take care of
you and I didn't get that note early on
so but I'm a big believer that when you
get it you get it it doesn't matter when
as long as you get it you know last time
we talked you're 212 pounds yeah I'm
fighting middleweight these days I'm
down to 212. how much I'm around 205. I
float between 205 and 210 which is crazy
right that's like a a third of you I
mean no it really is that's my wife
bumped her head on my my shoulder the
other day she was I kind of missed the
big shoulder
what's the difference from you know your
life before I think it's just
um self-care is important and I think I
finally got there you know my last Vice
I got left is I'm still smoking
cigarettes but I'm working on that one
but my buddy of mine told me you gotta
knock them down in the order they're
killing you but the freedom of knowing
that uh I can move and you know I didn't
want to I came from a humble beginning I
made my way to success and I you know I
have a child and you know as you hit 50
I'm 53 now but when you hit 50 you start
doing that Dad math like if I can live
25 more years then he'll be 40 and
that'll be you know what I mean so I
want to be here for him and and I didn't
want to go through everything I've gone
through in my journey and be 60 and not
be able to get out of a chair you know
what I mean so it was time to make that
change and I'm really grateful I did man
it's been the best how has that been for
your relationship as a father because
that is something that's incredible when
you can move around and to be an example
you know I've been an example in a lot
of good ways for my child but I feel
like I wasn't a good example of Health
for him and so I want him to see that it
doesn't matter what age you are if you
are willing to do something a day at a
time you can change anything and that's
the message I wanted him to get doesn't
matter what you want to change doesn't
matter when you want to change it all it
takes is today just do today if you can
do today and everything else take care
of itself what does your day-to-day look
like like your workout your eating how
does that work is somebody bringing up a
meal to you my wonderful producers
Christy Cecil and and Robin they uh they
put I asked them to put a weight bench
in some of those adjustable weights in
my giant trailer so that I can get a
workout in here and there and my diet is
you know I eat like a French woman I eat
three bites I put my of any head in
there and I light a cigarette that's it
I just I go small but I I very healthy
and I like all the people I used to make
fun of to be honest with you but now
like the fat guy's still in me so I eat
vicariously like if I see somebody when
I'm like get that gravy you need to come
on dig in there man you ain't do you
remember this is there anything you miss
like certain foods you miss you know no
because man I think I got my fill I
think I got my fill and now I'm at the
place where I can have a couple bites of
something decadent if I want I just I
just I'm free and I don't ever want to
go back so it's not it's not a it's not
an onus for me okay so what advice do
you have for folks out there that are
going and starting this journey if if
you're trying to lose weight a day at a
time that's the most important thing I
had gastric bypass surgery almost two
I'll be two years in July and I
chickened out from doing it like twice
it took me five years to make that
decision and the only thing I would say
is I understand that the operation is
not the it's not the end it's the
beginning because what you have to
commit to on the other side of it is
what you need to look at because if
you're not willing to commit to you have
to take vitamins every day you have to
get 75 ounces of water every day you got
to get 30 grams of protein every day if
you're not willing to commit to that
routine
don't do it but if you're ready to
commit to that on a daily basis
in the pudding what stops you the other
two times the other two well the first
time I went in there and wanted to give
you the consultation for the surgery you
know those little cups you get with
ketchup they put that on the table and
they said that's what your stomach's
going to look like after the surgery Mr
Gardell and I ran out like Daffy Duck
going through a wall I was just like I
couldn't even get my head around that
but as my knees started to hurt more as
my blood numbers started to get worse
and worse you know in this life
sometimes you have to surrender and if
you look up the textbook definition of
surrender it is conceived to The Winning
Side
so if you can turn that perspective
valve 20 degrees you can look at that
like you know what I don't know how to
do this I need some help and asking for
help is the thing people are most
terrified about but is it is the very
thing where strength is born in my
opinion when you could when you are
strong enough to say I can't do this on
my own then the troops come up over the
hill damn and you really are on The
Winning Side now
I also felt like his eyes were following
me like the Mona Lisa or those cat
clocks
all right as we count down to this end
of season four what can you tell us what
are we gonna see what's gonna happen
because I know you two are trying to
figure out how to spend time together
we're trying to get each other because
rabashola is headed for medical school
Bob has just opened a manufacturing
plant in his thing and and they're in
that place of when couples work and
they're both working towards a goal you
can kind of sometimes grow apart so you
have to find that way to come back
together and I think uh Gene and the
Gang have come up with a incredible
final episode it's really it's got all
the hearts and feels and it's really
funny it's got a good Cliffhanger and
that's all the elements you want for a
final well I will just say there's
another visit from my Father which was
one of my favorite episodes I've ever
done that show by the by Joel Murray
who's just incredible how's it working
with Gina because her comedy was always
about Nigerian culture and now it's
translated well to television I think
she has done something that has been
amazing to watch Sheen I'm a stand-up
comic and I ended up starring in a
sitcom and staring in the sitcom Gina
started with stand up which she's
fantastic at and then became a writer
and an actress and an executive producer
I mean that's and that's an incredible
thing to pull off ladies please we all
agree this is abisola's fault I was Gina
with the power now
she's the same man you know she'll tell
you again don't ask unless you want to
know but she's straightforward man and
she's always looking to make the show
better and and that's what we need and
and the most thing the most important
thing she adds into our writer's room is
authenticity that was fun huh yes
you had a good time
you just got renewed how good is that
it's been an amazing run man to to be uh
on a show that's going into its Fifth
Season you know that's like catching a
unicorn and uh I'm very very grateful
that we've been able to to do this with
this show we found a nice audience we
keep getting a little bigger and a
little bigger each year and uh I think
we're putting out a good message and I
think people adhere to that 6.9 million
people
6.9 million people all followers we
don't call you followers we call you
fans
and let me just say this to you yes sir
when they propose this show I was like
wait a minute oh
from the Midwest falls in love with a
Nigerian immigrant I was like as a
comedy yeah
it I mean I was like come on guys does
that make sense you know man
um Chuck Laurie changed my life with
Mike and Molly so when he called me
about this one it wouldn't matter like I
just trust that man to do what he does
and be what him Eddie gordetsky and Al
Higgins and Gina yasharray came up with
I mean it just sounded so interesting
and it was such a departure from the
last thing I did but it's the secret
sauce is the same It's All About Love
wins it's all about love if you start
there you can go anywhere and I mean you
get to blend cultures which is it can be
funny if you're open-hearted and then
you know when you marry someone you
marry their family and so you have to
navigate that and I like that we show
that it doesn't matter what you look
like you say I do to somebody you say I
do to all of them so you have the crazy
uncle you have the crazy sister-in-law
you have the and and we have that
beautiful Dynamic and learning how to
navigate that I think makes for great
comment thank you
[Music]